a routine parliamentary session descends
into violence
A Member of Parliament slaps and kicks
one of his colleagues the woman was
pregnant and has since miscarried even
so some politicians say she deserved the
beating
the MP that hit her she salted his
religious leader I disapprove of what
happened
charges have been laid against the
offending MP but despite robust new laws
to protect women and girls in Senegal
research shows 68 of women victims of
such crimes never speak out
19 years to summon up the courage to
bring an end to her marriage and the
daily blows that came with living with
her husband
he would beat her unconscious hitting
her so hard that he damaged the nerves
at the base of her skull leaving her
blind in the right eye and bang
eventually left him and approached the
police but he continues to threaten her
painful it really hurts that he is still
free after everything he has done he
continues to harass me and goes looking
for me but I want to live my life her
closest relatives knew about the
violence but did nothing to stop it
according to the UN one in three women
worldwide experienced sexual or domestic
violence
the rising number cases is linked to
fear of denouncing such acts and certain
level of negligence and normalization of
domestic violence it is certainly the
case in the household and Beyond
the brawl in Parliament has sparked a
national conversation about the
treatment of women and it's not the only
case in the public spotlight
we're outside the main courthouse in
Dakar where Usman sonko the main on
position leader is standing trial for
rape look at the headlines it says she
is finally ready
the moment she has been waiting for this
one the sweet and beautiful duel there's
an undertone of sexism where the onus is
on the woman to prove her innocence
rather than on the man
few women are willing to come forward
many of those who do are still afraid
but defiant rebuilding their lives one
step at a time Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
Dakar